bine ai revenit la înțelegerea informației și computației cuantice, numele meu este John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic pentru educație la IBM
Quantum aceasta este a 10-a lecție din serie și este a doua lecție din al treilea modul, care tratează formularea generală
a informației cuantice această lecție este despre canale, care reprezintă schimbări în
sisteme ce stochează informație cuantică aceasta include operații utile, cum ar fi cele efectuate de
gate-uri unitare și Quantum circuits, dar și schimbări pe care am prefera să le evităm, cum ar fi zgomotul; putem descrie și măsurători
ca și canale, iar asta este ceva ce vom aprofunda în lecția următoare termenul canal ne vine din
teoria informației, care, printre altele, studiază capacitatea de a transporta informație prin comunicări zgomotoase
canale; astfel, când ne gândim la canale, ne gândim abstract la comunicare
canale poate părea ciudat să te gândești la o computație complexă ca la un canal de comunicare, dar avem nevoie de
un cuvânt care să se refere la noțiunea generală de proces ce schimbă informația într-un anumit mod și, vrei nu vrei, cuvântul
canal a rămas, fără îndoială datorită în mare parte impactului enorm pe care teoria informației și în particular
lucrarea lui Claude Shannon din anii '40 a avut-o asupra informației și computației cuantice; iată o prezentare generală a
lecției: vom începe cu noțiunile de bază, inclusiv definiția unui canal, dar și modul în care operațiile unitare din formularea simplificată
a informației cuantice pot fi descrise ca și canale; vom vorbi și despre faptul că combinațiile convexe de canale sunt canale, iar dacă ești
curios de ce această noțiune de convexitate tot apare, este pentru că este o noțiune matematică fundamental importantă în teoria
informației cuantice; vom vedea și câteva exemple de canale, în special canale qubit, care vor reapărea din când
în când pe parcursul restului lecției; în a doua parte a lecției, vom discuta trei moduri diferite prin care putem reprezenta canale
matematic; în particular, vom vorbi despre reprezentările Stinespring, reprezentările Krauss și Choy
reprezentări denumite după trei persoane a căror lucrare a fost importantă în dezvoltarea acestor diferite reprezentări; în a treia și
ultima parte a lecției, vom discuta o demonstrație matematică ce stabilește că aceste trei reprezentări sunt de fapt echivalente, precum și faptul că ele
toate caracterizează corect definiția unui canal; este o demonstrație matematică cu adevărat ingenioasă în opinia mea și sper că va adăuga ceva
claritate acestor reprezentări diferite, modului în care se relaționează și cum funcționează în general; vom începe cu noțiunile de bază și
vom aborda întrebarea: ce sunt canalele? după cum am sugerat deja la începutul lecției, canalele descriu schimbări
specific schimbări în timp discret în sisteme ce stochează informație cuantică; când ne referim la o schimbare în timp
discret, ne gândim pur și simplu la o schimbare care apare între două momente distincte în timp, spre deosebire de un
proces continuu, de exemplu, ce are sens să fie gândit pe perioade de timp infinitezimal de mici; canalele includ operații utile, cum ar fi
operațiile unitare efectuate de Quantum Gates și circuits, dar și schimbări datorate zgomotului; de exemplu, pentru
scopurile acestei lecții totuși, vom gândi în mare parte canalele în termeni matematici abstracți și nu va fi nevoie particulară
să distingem între ce este util și ce nu; denumirile tipice pentru canale includ literele grecești majuscule fi,
Psi și Phi, și vom folosi litere diferite pentru a ne referi la anumite canale specifice; într-o situație simplă în care
avem un sistem care se află într-o stare descrisă de o matrice de densitate rho și aplicăm un canal fi acelui sistem, rezultatul
este un sistem a cărui stare este descrisă de matricea de densitate fi a lui rho; astfel, ne gândim la un
canal fi dat ca la o funcție ce poate fi aplicată matricelor de densitate de o anumită dimensiune, sau cu alte cuvinte
matricelor de densitate ale unui anumit sistem căruia îi aplicăm acest canal; există câteva cerințe pe care canalele trebuie să le satisfacă pentru a fi
considerate canale valide; în primul rând, canalele sunt mapări liniare; aceasta este complet analogă cu situația pe care o avem atât
în formularea simplificată a informației cuantice, unde operațiile pe vectorii de stare cuantici sunt în mod necesar liniare,
cât și în formularea standard a informației clasice, unde operațiile probabilistice sunt liniare; ai putea alege să pui la îndoială această cerință
de bază a liniarității dacă ai vrea cu adevărat, dar dacă dorim o teorie consistentă atât cu teoria probabilităților
cât și cu alegerea de a reprezenta stările cuantice cu matrice de densitate, atunci nu avem de fapt nicio alegere și trebuie să acceptăm că canalele sunt liniare
a doua cerință este că canalele transformă matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate; are sens perfect, deoarece dacă am ales să reprezentăm
stările sistemelor cu matrice de densitate și aplicăm un canal unui sistem aflat în o stare oarecare, atunci rezultatul trebuie să fie o stare validă și deci
reprezentată de o matrice de densitate; există totuși un punct foarte important de adăugat aici, și anume că această cerință
trebuie să fie adevărată nu numai dacă aplicăm un canal unui sistem izolat a cărui stare este descrisă de o matrice de densitate
ci și dacă avem un sistem compus a cărui stare este descrisă de o matrice de densitate și aplicăm canalul doar
unei părți a acelui sistem; acestea sunt cerințele pe care le impunem canalelor și putem vedea că sunt foarte mult
analogice cerințelor pe care le avem pentru operații atât în formularea simplificată a informației cuantice cât și în formularea standard
a informației clasice; în formularea simplificată a informației cuantice, operațiile sunt reprezentate de matrice unitare deoarece ele
corespund precis mapărilor liniare ce transformă întotdeauna vectorii de stare cuantici în vectori de stare cuantici pentru
un sistem dat și, în mod similar, operațiile probabilistice sunt reprezentate de matrice stocastice deoarece acestea sunt cele care
transformă întotdeauna vectorii de probabilitate în vectori de probabilitate; aici lucrăm cu matrice de densitate și există
această cerință adițională privind sistemele compuse, care se dovedește a nu fi necesară pentru vectorii de stare cuantici
sau vectorii de probabilitate, dar în rest cerințele sunt analogice și, într-un anumit sens, ne sunt impuse de alegerea
de a reprezenta stările cuantice prin matrice de densitate; iată câteva detalii suplimentare despre canale, inclusiv o convenție
despre modul în care ne vom gândi la sistemele de intrare și ieșire ale unui canal pe parcursul lecției, precum și mai multe detalii
despre cerința că canalele transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate; în primul rând, fiecare canal
se presupune că are un sistem de intrare și un sistem de ieșire; putem numi aceste sisteme cum dorim, dar pe tot parcursul
lecției voi folosi numele X pentru a mă referi la sistemul de intrare și numele Y pentru a mă referi la sistemul de ieșire; conceptual vorbind, canalul
transformă sistemul de intrare în sistemul de ieșire, deci sistemele de intrare și ieșire nu coexistă niciodată simultan;
pornim cu X, canalul este aplicat sau efectuat, iar rezultatul este că X a fost transformat în Y, a cărui stare este
determinată de maparea liniară asociată canalului; sistemele de intrare și ieșire ale unui canal nu trebuie să fie aceleași și în particular
nu trebuie să aibă același număr de stări clasice; totuși, se poate ca sistemul de intrare și cel de ieșire să fie de fapt același sistem, sau cu alte
WEBVTT
cuvinte X egal Y, caz în care ne imaginăm pur și simplu că fi schimbă starea sistemului, și într-adevăr aceasta este
de foarte multe ori situația care ne interesează, dar această posibilitate este consistentă cu primul punct în sensul că nu avem niciodată
sistemele de intrare și ieșire existând ca două sisteme separate în același timp, și în orice caz va fi convenabil
pentru scopurile acestei lecții să folosim litere diferite, adică X și Y, pentru a ne referi la sistemele de intrare și ieșire
doar pentru a ne ajuta să ne menținem claritatea; acum să intrăm în mai multe detalii despre cerința că canalele transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate
în matrice de densitate; să presupunem că introducem un nou sistem Z în ecuație; să
numim gamma mulțimea stărilor clasice ale acestui nou sistem; imaginează-ți acum că formăm un nou sistem compus ZX
constând din noul sistem împreună cu sistemul de intrare X al unui canal fi și să presupunem că acest sistem compus se află
într-o stare descrisă de o matrice de densitate rho; aceasta poate fi o stare cuantică arbitrară a acestei perechi, dar indiferent de stare
este întotdeauna posibil să exprimi matricea de densitate Rho în forma afișată pe ecran, unde atât A cât și B
parcurg mulțimea stărilor clasice gamma și fiecare rho AB este o matrice ale cărei rânduri și coloane corespund oricărei
mulțimi de stări clasice ale lui X și nu trebuie să dăm un nume acelei mulțimi de stări clasice în acest moment; ca să fie clar, fiecare rho AB nu este în mod necesar o
matrice de densitate în sine, dar întreaga matrice rho este în mod necesar o matrice de densitate; când aplicăm canalul fi
sistemului X, acesta se transformă în Y, deci rămânem cu perechea ZY și modul în care determinăm
starea acestei perechi după efectuarea lui fi doar pe X este să evaluăm maparea liniară fi pe fiecare dintre matricele rho a
un alt mod de a spune asta este că luăm produsul tensorial al mapării fi cu maparea identitate pe matrice pătrate cu rânduri și coloane
corespunzătoare lui gamma și aceasta corespunde la a nu face nimic cu noul sistem Z; dar aceasta este o descriere echivalentă
și nu necesită intrarea în detalii despre produse tensoriale ale mapărilor de această formă; ele
funcționează totuși într-un mod destul de direct, analog cu modul în care funcționează pentru vectori și matrice; un mod de a vizualiza asta este
în termeni de matrice bloc, și dacă facem ipoteza simplificatoare că mulțimea stărilor clasice gamma constă din
numerele întregi între 0 și N minus unu pentru un întreg pozitiv M, atunci devine ușor să scriem toate acestea după cum este
arătat chiar aici; acum pentru a reitera cerința pe care o impunem lui fi pentru ca acesta să fie un canal valid, trebuie să obținem întotdeauna o matrice de densitate
din acest proces și aceasta trebuie să fie adevărat indiferent de ce alegere facem pentru sistemul Z, dar și
alegerea pe care o facem pentru rho, cu condiția că este o matrice de densitate; poate părea o cerință destul de strictă și
poate părea și foarte dificil de verificat, dar după cum vom vedea la sfârșitul lecției, nu este chiar atât de strictă
sau dificil de verificat; în particular, avem caracterizări matematice frumoase pentru această condiție
care sunt conectate cu reprezentările diferite despre care vom vorbi puțin mai târziu în lecție; acum să aruncăm o privire la câteva exemple de canale
începând cu o întreagă categorie de canale numite canale unitare; în termeni simpli, acestea sunt operații unitare
la fel ca în formularea simplificată a informației cuantice, privite ca și canale; ca să fim preciși, să presupunem că U este o matrice
unitară ce reprezintă o operație unitară pe un sistem X; astfel în formularea simplificată a informației cuantice
am înmulți această matrice cu un vector de stare cuantic dat pentru a determina acțiunea pe care acea operație o are asupra acelui vector de stare cuantic; modul
în care funcționează asta pentru matricele de densitate este că înmulțim matricea de densitate pe stânga cu U și pe dreapta cu U
dagger; în termeni matematici ne referim la această operație ca conjugare prin matricea U; aceasta este consistentă cu KSI
braSai ca matrice de densitate ce descrie starea reprezentată de vectorul de stare cuantic s și este destul de
ușor de verificat că în particular dacă am efectua U pe vectorul de stare cuantic Ki, am obține U * Ki și
reprezentarea sa ca matrice de densitate este dată de acel vector înmulțit cu transpusa sa conjugată, adică U * Ki * braSai * U
dagger când evaluăm transpusa conjugată a lui U * Ki; astfel, modul în care este definit acest canal
are sens pentru stările pure și când combinăm asta cu liniaritatea, vedem că are sens pentru matricele de densitate în
general, datorită faptului că fiecare matrice de densitate poate fi exprimată ca o combinație convexă de stări pure; această
definiție ne dă întotdeauna un canal valid pentru orice alegere a unei operații unitare u; în particular, conjugarea prin
o matrice unitară ca aceasta nu schimbă urma unei matrice și dacă conjugăm orice matrice pozitiv semi-definită
cu orice matrice, vom obține o altă matrice pozitiv semi-definită și este destul de ușor de obținut asta
direct din definiția matricelor pozitiv semi-definite; astfel, matricele de densitate sunt întotdeauna mapate în matrice de densitate
și toate acestea rămân valabile chiar dacă tensoriem U cu matricea identitate de orice dimensiune, ceea ce este echivalent
cu aplicarea acestui canal doar la o parte dintr-un sistem compus; iată un exemplu cu adevărat simplu al unui canal unitar: să presupunem că
luăm U ca matricea identitate; acesta este în mod evident un canal valid numit canalul identitate; a
nu face nimic este cu siguranță o operație liniară și dacă pornim cu o matrice de densitate și nu facem nimic cu ea,
va fi în continuare o matrice de densitate, deci acesta este un canal valid; oamenii folosesc simboluri diferite pentru a denota acest canal,
uneori este exact același simbol pe care îl folosim pentru matricea identitate, ceea ce poate fi puțin confuz, dar în general nu este; eu folosesc
literele ID, prescurtare pentru identitate, doar pentru a evita orice confuzie, și această notație este destul de comună; poate părea un
canal foarte plictisitor, dar în contextul transmiterii informației este de fapt un canal perfect unde
receptorul primește exact ceea ce trimite expeditorul, ceea ce în mod tipic este ceea ce se dorește cel mai mult în acel context; un alt mod în care putem
obține o mulțime de exemple de canale este să luăm combinații convexe de canale sau, cu alte cuvinte, să le facem media
și faptul că putem face asta este un aspect important al canalelor; pentru a explica asta în mai multe detalii, să pornim cu două canale F0 și F1, să
spunem, împreună cu un număr real P între 0 și unu și ca să fie clar, presupunem că aceste două canale au
același sistem de intrare, adică X, precum și același sistem de ieșire, adică Y; și acum să ne gândim ce se întâmplă dacă decidem
să aplicăm primul canal F0 cu probabilitatea p și altfel, cu probabilitatea rămasă 1 minus P, aplicăm
al doilea canal F1; de exemplu, poate alegem aleatoriu un bit cu acele probabilități și apoi folosim acest bit aleatoriu
pentru a determina ce canal să aplicăm; procedând astfel, efectiv aplicăm un nou canal pe care l-am putea numi psi
dat de o combinație convexă a celor două canale cu care am început și pe care îl putem exprima după cum este scris
pe ecran; putem lua întotdeauna combinații liniare de mapări liniare de acest fel și modul în care o combinație liniară
WEBVTT
de mapări liniare este definită pe o intrare dată este că luăm aceeași combinație liniară a ieșirilor
asta poate părea oarecum trivial, dar are sens; ieșirea pe care o obținem din acest scenariu ipotetic este pur și simplu media ponderată
a ieșirilor pe care le-am obține de la cele două canale originale; cu toate acestea, acesta este un canal nou și
dacă F0 și F1 erau canale valide, atunci cu siguranță această nouă mapare va fi și ea un canal valid; un alt mod de a spune
asta în termeni matematici este că mulțimea tuturor canalelor de la un sistem de intrare dat la un sistem de ieșire dat este
convexă, și aceasta este o proprietate matematică importantă a canalelor; putem face asta mai general: dacă avem M canale F0 până la F m minus unu, să
spunem, împreună cu un vector de probabilitate care ne spune care este probabilitatea pentru fiecare canal, atunci obținem un canal nou prin medierea canalelor corespunzător; astfel
într-un anumit sens aceasta este o sursă nesfârșită de canale noi; de exemplu, clasa așa-numitelor canale unitare mixte este ceea ce
obținem luând combinații convexe de canale unitare; adică, dacă avem M matrice unitare u0 până la u m minus
unu, toate de aceeași dimensiune, împreună cu vectorul de probabilitate, atunci dacă luăm media ponderată a canalelor
corespunzătoare matricelor unitare individuale după cum este arătat pe ecran, vom obține un canal și canalele
care pot fi scrise astfel se numesc canale unitare mixte; nu orice canal este un canal unitar mixt; nu putem obține
fiecare canal în acest mod, dar ele apar destul de des; acum vom analiza câteva exemple specifice
de canale; acestea vor fi toate exemple de canale de la un qubit la un qubit, care se numesc canale
qubit pe scurt; primul se numește canalul qubit de resetare și ideea este că acest canal resetează un qubit
la starea zero; folosim litera grecească majusculă Lambda pentru a denota acest canal și modul în care poți reține ce face acest canal este să
te gândești la sfera Bloch; Lambda majusculă seamănă cam cu o săgeată care indică în sus, iar starea zero se află în vârful sferei Bloch, deci este ca și cum
ar indica locația ieșirii; modul în care este definit în termeni matematici este că Lambda a lui rho egal urma lui rho înmulțit cu ket0 bra0; astfel
dacă îl evaluăm pe orice matrice de densitate rho, vom obține starea zero ca matrice de densitate; este firesc să ne întrebăm
de ce avem nevoie de urmă; nu am putea pur și simplu defini Lambda a lui rho ca ket zero bra zero fără urma lui rho în față?
Răspunsul la această întrebare este nu; canalele trebuie să fie mapări liniare și nu ar fi liniară dacă am elimina urma lui rho; de asemenea, ține minte că
uneori trebuie să știm cum funcționează un canal ca mapare liniară pe intrări care nu sunt matrice de densitate; de exemplu, după cum
am văzut mai devreme, dacă vrem să știm ce face un canal când îl aplicăm unui sistem compus, trebuie
să evaluăm acel canal pe blocurile individuale ale unei matrice bloc mai mari, și deși întreaga matrice bloc poate fi
o matrice de densitate, blocurile individuale în general nu vor fi; deci să vedem exact ce face acest canal când îl aplicăm
doar la o parte dintr-un sistem compus și mai specific ce face când îl aplicăm unuia din doi qubiți care
formează un ebit; ca să fim preciși, să presupunem că A și B sunt qubiți care ca pereche se află în starea Bell fi plus, și aplicăm Lambda
să zicem primului qubit A; pentru a afla ce se întâmplă, să exprimăm mai întâi starea fi plus ca matrice de densitate și
pentru exemplul acesta să folosim notația Dirac pentru asta; iată starea fi plus ca vector de stare cuantic și iată ce obținem când
înmulțim acest vector cu transpusa sa conjugată și îl extindem; putem apoi aplica canalul primului qubit și evalua ce obținem; iată
Lambda aplicat primului qubit și iată ce obținem când evaluăm fiecare dintre termeni; urma lui ket0 bra0 este unu
și la fel este și urma lui ket1 bra1, deci în acele două cazuri ieșirea canalului este ket0 bra0 și asta explică
cei doi termeni din răspuns; urma lui ket zero bra unu pe de altă parte este zero, la fel ca și urma lui ket1 bra zero
și astfel acei doi termeni se evaluează la zero și prin urmare nu contribuie cu nimic la răspuns; acum putem simplifica un
pic și ceea ce obținem este starea zero pentru primul qubit care este A și starea complet mixtă pentru
al doilea qubit care este B; remarcă în particular că nu am obținut starea plus pentru B, ceea ce nu ar fi neapărat
o ghicire greșită dacă nu am ști nimic despre matricele de densitate și ne-am uita doar la reprezentarea vectorului de stare cuantic al stării, dar
acesta nu este modul în care funcționează acest canal și nu există niciun canal care ar putea funcționa în acel mod; canalul Lambda se numește canalul qubit de resetare, dar
modul în care funcționează este mai degrabă ca și cum arunci qubit-ul de intrare la gunoi și îl înlocuiești cu un qubit proaspăt în starea zero, dar acesta de fapt este
singurul canal qubit care produce întotdeauna starea zero; iată un alt exemplu de canal qubit cunoscut ca
canalul complet defazant; acesta este notat cu Delta și modul în care funcționează este că lasă intrările diagonale
ale oricărei matrice 2x2 nemodificate și anulează intrările din afara diagonalei; Delta este echivalentul grec al literei D din
alfabetul latin și acesta prescurtează diagonal, deci acesta este un mod de a reține ce face acest canal; putem
de asemenea exprima acest canal folosind notația Dirac după cum este arătat pe ecran și ca să fie clar, ieșirea
este întotdeauna o matrice 2x2, deci în particular cele două ieșiri de zero se referă la matricea 2x2 cu toate elementele zero; de multe ori
facem asta și am văzut asta anterior în această serie; simbolul zero este în general folosit poate ambiguu pentru a denota elementul zero
al oricărui lucru despre care vorbim, fie scalari, vectori, matrice sau altceva; să facem același lucru pe care l-am făcut anterior pentru
canalul qubit de resetare și să vedem ce se întâmplă dacă aplicăm acest canal la jumătate dintr-un ebit; configurația este aceeași, deci nu voi
trece prin acea parte și rezultatul este starea arătată pe ecran, care este esențial un bit aleatoriu comun; deci ce
a făcut acest canal a fost practic să convertească un ebit într-o pereche perfect corelată de biți aleatorii clasici
și asta este consistent cu o interpretare mai generală a acestui canal; anulând intrările din afara diagonalei ale unei matrice de densitate, efectiv
aruncăm lucrurile cuantice dintr-o matrice de densitate, lăsând o matrice de densitate diagonală care reprezintă o
stare probabilistică clasică; un alt mod de a gândi asta este că acest canal reprezintă un canal clasic fără zgomot perfect care transmite un bit
deci dacă punem o stare zero sau o stare unu sau o combinație convexă a acelor două stări în canal, atunci acea stare iese nemodificată, dar dacă încearcă
să pui o stare cuantică în el, cum ar fi o stare plus de exemplu, este ca și cum canalul măsoară acea stare cu o măsurătoare în baza standard și apoi
transmite rezultatul clasic; un ultim exemplu de canal qubit este canalul complet depolarizant; ce
face acest canal este să producă întotdeauna starea complet mixtă, deci este similar într-un anumit sens cu canalul qubit de resetare
cu excepția că obținem o stare complet mixtă mai puțin utilă în loc de un qubit inițializat; un mod natural
de a gândi despre acest canal este că reprezintă o formă extremă de zgomot și în ceea ce privește canalele qubit
nu există ceva mai zgomotos de atât; nu am un mnemonic bun de oferit pentru a reține ce face acesta, în afară de a spune că Omega este ultima
literă a alfabetului grec și este uneori asociată cu sfârșitul tuturor lucrurilor și poate acesta este ce se întâmplă
WEBVTT
cu toți qubiții în final; în ceea ce privește zgomotul, este destul de extrem, dar un lucru pe care îl putem face este să considerăm o combinație convexă
a acestui canal și a canalului identitate, cu poate o probabilitate mică epsilon pentru depolarizare
completă; aceasta este o formă mai puțin extremă de zgomot unde o stare qubit dată va fi lăsată în mare parte intactă, dar există
o mică șansă să devină complet mixtă; din punct de vedere geometric, putem gândi asta ca o ușoară contracție a sferei Bloch spre centru
și apropo, putem face ceva similar cu canalul complet defazant pentru a modela procesul de decoerență, de exemplu, unde lucrurile
devin ușor mai clasice printr-un anumit proces; deci acelea sunt trei exemple de bază de canale qubit și
ne vom întoarce la ele în principal ca sursă de exemple pe parcursul restului lecției; urmează să discutăm reprezentările matematice
ale canalelor, începând cu o întrebare de bază: mapările liniare de la vectori la vectori pot fi întotdeauna
reprezentate prin matrice într-un mod familiar, adică acțiunea mapării liniare este descrisă prin înmulțire
matrice-vector; dar canalele sunt mapări liniare de la matrice la matrice, nu de la vectori la vectori; deci în
general, cum putem exprima canalele în termeni matematici? uneori pentru canale speciale avem o formulă simplă
care le descrie și acela a fost cazul în exemplele de canale qubit pe care le-am discutat deja, dar asta nu este
practic în general deoarece nu va exista întotdeauna o formulă atât de frumoasă; ca punct de comparație, în formularea simplificată
a informației cuantice, folosim matrice unitare pentru a reprezenta operații pe vectorii de stare cuantici
fiecare matrice unitară reprezintă o operație validă și fiecare operație validă poate fi exprimată ca o matrice unitară; deci în
esență, ceea ce întreabă această întrebare este cum facem asta pentru canale; și răspunsul la această întrebare este că există de fapt mai multe moduri de a reprezenta
canalele în termeni matematici; în particular, vom discuta trei moduri diferite de reprezentare a canalelor care sunt
denumite după trei persoane a căror muncă a jucat un rol important în dezvoltarea lor: Stinespring, Krauss și Choy
mai întâi vom vedea cum funcționează aceste reprezentări diferite și apoi în ultima parte a lecției vom vedea cum se relaționează cele trei reprezentări și în
particular cum putem converti între ele; vom vedea de asemenea că aceste reprezentări surprind precis cerințele pe care le avem pe canale
și anume că sunt mapări liniare și că transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate, chiar și când
sunt aplicate doar la o parte dintr-un sistem compus; primele sunt reprezentările Stinespring; Willam Forest Stinespring
a fost un matematician care nu a lucrat în informații cuantice și reprezentările Stinespring, după cum le voi descrie,
sunt într-un anumit sens doar un derivat al lucrării sale din teoria operatorilor din anii 1950, dar această muncă a fost cu certitudine
o parte importantă în dezvoltarea matematicii pe care se bazează canalele cuantice; ideea din spatele acestui mod de reprezentare a canalelor este că fiecare
canal poate fi implementat într-un anumit mod pe care îl voi descrie acum; mai întâi formăm un sistem compus constând din
intrarea oricărui canal pe care îl implementăm împreună cu un sistem workspace inițializat; apoi
se efectuează o operație unitară pe sistemul compus și în final orice parte a sistemului compus rezultat
care corespunde ieșirii canalului este lăsată intactă sau la ieșire, iar restul este eliminat sau urmărit; este util să
exprimăm asta sub forma unui diagrama și este cel mai simplu să pornim cu cazul special în care intrarea și
sistemele de ieșire sunt aceleași; această diagramă de altfel este la fel ca o diagramă circuit cuantic cu excepția că firele
reprezintă sisteme arbitrare și nu neapărat qubiți singulari; deci pornim cu sistemul de intrare X aflat în o anumită
stare rho; introducem un sistem workspace inițializat W și în această diagramă presupun că Zero este o stare clasică
a lui W și luăm ket0 ca starea inițializată a sistemului, dar am putea alternativ fixa orice stare pură
a lui W și să o considerăm starea inițializată; efectuăm apoi o anumită operație unitară pe perechea WX și apoi
urmărim sistemul workspace și scoatem X; în diagramă de altfel folosesc simbolul de împământare din
ingineria electrică pentru a indica că W este eliminat; aceasta nu este neapărat convențional și nu
vei găsi acel simbol în Qiskit; acolo pur și simplu ignori qubiții care nu te interesează; ideea este că vreau să am un simbol care să facă
clar că eliminăm sistemul pentru scopurile acestei discuții; în general nu avem neapărat nevoie ca
sistemele de intrare și ieșire să fie aceleași, deci putem avea de exemplu un sistem de ieșire Y împreună cu un sistem
gunoi G care este urmărit; pentru ca U să fie unitar trebuie să fie o matrice pătrată, deci există o presupunere
că perechea G Y împreună are același număr de stări clasice ca și perechea WX; de exemplu, poate aceste sisteme
constau din qubiți și sistemul de intrare X constă din 5 qubiți, iar W constă din 10 qubiți, deci U este o operație unitară
pe 15 qubiți; ar putea fi atunci că Y constă din doar patru qubiți, ceea ce înseamnă că G constă din 11 qubiți
sau poate acestea nu sunt qubiți deloc; tot ce este important este că WX împreună și GY împreună au același număr de
stări clasice astfel încât U poate fi unitar; o descriere a unui canal de acest fel se numește reprezentare Stinespring a canalului; acum este
destul de simplu să argumentăm că orice mapare fi care poate fi descrisă în acest mod este de fapt un canal valid; în
particular, dacă pornim cu matricea de densitate și atașăm un sistem workspace adițional, vom fi cu siguranță
lăsați cu o matrice de densitate; am observat deja că aplicarea unei operații unitare ne dă un canal valid și
dacă avem o matrice de densitate a unui sistem compus și urmărim unul dintre sisteme, vom fi din nou lăsați cu o matrice de densitate; deci când compunem
acești pași vom fi garantați că transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate, și este și liniară
ceea ce nu este deloc clar în acest moment este că fiecare canal poate într-adevăr fi implementat în acest mod pentru o anumită alegere
a sistemului workspace și a sistemului gunoi, precum și a operației unitare U desigur, dar asta este adevărat și vom
vedea de ce la sfârșitul lecției; iată un exemplu de reprezentare Stinespring pentru canalul
qubit complet defazant și ca să fie clar acum, firele sunt qubiți și acesta este un
CNOT obișnuit; este foarte simplu: qubit-ul de intrare se află sus și introducem un qubit workspace inițializat la starea zero
efectuăm o operație CNOT unde qubit-ul de intrare este controlul și qubit-ul workspace este
ținta, iar apoi qubit-ul workspace este urmărit; intuitiv vorbind, are sens
că aceasta ar trebui să implementeze canalul complet defazant deoarece CNOT acționează cam ca o măsurătoare în baza standard pe qubit-ul de sus
prin copierea stării sale clasice pe qubit-ul de jos, iar apoi rezultatul este aruncat
dar putem trece și printr-un calcul și desigur este o idee bună să facem asta deoarece cu adevărat
WEBVTT
nu ar trebui să avem prea multă încredere în intuiția noastră; putem începe prin a scrie reprezentarea ca matrice de densitate a
celor doi qubiți după ce qubit-ul workspace a fost introdus și remarcă că folosim convenția de ordonare Qiskit ca
de obicei, unde qubit-ul de jos este cel din stânga și qubit-ul de sus este cel din dreapta; putem exprima această matrice de densitate
explicit ca o matrice 4x4 reală după cum este arătată pe ecran și apoi calculăm efectul
pe care gate-ul CNOT îl are pe această matrice de densitate, deci conjugăm cu matricea unitară asociată cu acest
gate, ținând din nou minte convenția de ordonare Qiskit, deci aceasta este matricea unitară corectă
și rezultatul este arătat aici; în esență, gate-ul CNOT
a permutat intrările matricei noastre originale un pic, astfel încât acum intrările posibil nenule se află în
cele patru colțuri; rămâne de calculat urma parțială și am putea face asta direct din matrice, dar o
alternativă este să convertim la notația Dirac după cum este arătat pe ecran și apoi devine destul de ușor să evaluăm
ce se întâmplă când urmărim qubit-ul din stânga în cadrul fiecărui termen, iar rezultatul este că doar
termenii corespunzători intrărilor diagonale ale lui rho supraviețuiesc și astfel am defazat qubit-ul după cum
era de așteptat; ca întotdeauna, verifică asta singur în ritmul tău dacă alegi să o faci; este un
exemplu bun pentru a exersa lucrul cu matricele de densitate și cu urmele
parțiale; acesta nu este singurul mod de a implementa canalul complet defazant; iată o reprezentare Stinespring alternativă pentru acest
canal; nu voi trece prin calcul în detaliu în acest videoclip, dar îl voi arăta pe scurt în caz că vrei să faci pauză și să ai o
privire mai atentă; modul în care funcționează este similar cu primul, dar detaliile sunt
diferite; de această dată pornim cu un gate Hadamard pe qubit-ul workspace, care îl pune în starea plus; și dacă
extindem produsul tensorial, obținem matricea arătată pe ecran; pentru a aplica gate-ul controlled-Z,
conjugăm cu matricea unitară asociată și rezultatul este injectarea unor semne minus în
matrice; în particular, ultimul rând și ultima coloană sunt ambele înmulțite cu minus 1
și de această dată ar fi destul de complicat să convertim la notația Dirac, deci vom calcula urma parțială
direct; când urmărim primul din doi qubiți, obținem suma celor două blocuri diagonale 2x2
și astfel rezultatul final este din nou că am defazat qubit-ul; a fost rapid și dacă nu ești
obișnuit cu aceste tipuri de calcule, ia-ți timp și fă-o încet; viteza nu este importantă
aici; pentru a încheia acest exemplu, menționez că există o idee destul de simplă în spatele acestei implementări, care este
destul de bine exprimată de ultimul pas al calculului pe care tocmai l-am parcurs rapid; un mod mai succint de a spune asta
este că dacă facem media unei matrice de densitate qubit date cu acea matrice de densitate conjugată prin matricea Pauli Z, atunci
este același lucru cu defazarea; deci canalul complet defazant se întâmplă să fie un canal unitar mixt
unde fie nu facem nimic, adică efectuăm operația identitate, fie efectuăm un gate Z, fiecare
cu probabilitatea 1/2; bun de știut; deci în rezumat avem două reprezentări Stinespring diferite
ale canalului complet defazant și asta ne spune ceva important, și anume că reprezentările Stinespring nu sunt
unice și de fapt există un număr infinit de ele pentru orice canal dat; urmează să discutăm reprezentările Krauss
ale canalelor, care ne dau un mod convenabil formulaic de a exprima canalele prin înmulțire
matriceală și adunare; reprezentările Krauss sunt denumite după Karl Krauss, care este un fizician care, printre
altele, a elaborat o mulțime din detaliile matematice de bază ale canalelor și formularea generală a informației cuantice mai larg; în general, o
reprezentare Krauss este o expresie a unui canal care ia forma arătată pe ecran; în particular avem o
colecție de matrice care sunt numite A zero până la A n minus unu pentru un întreg pozitiv n și ele specifică
acțiunea canalului pe orice intrare rho dată conform formulei; pe scurt, conjugăm rho cu fiecare dintre aceste matrice
care sunt adesea denumite matrice Krauss în acest context și apoi adunăm rezultatul și aceasta ne dă ieșirea; toate aceste matrice trebuie să aibă
aceleași dimensiuni și în mod specific coloanele lor trebuie să corespundă stărilor clasice ale sistemului de intrare, iar
rândurile trebuie să corespundă stărilor clasice ale sistemului de ieșire; dacă acesta este cazul, atunci când luăm produsul AK * rho * AK dagger pentru orice
alegere de K obținem o matrice pătrată ale cărei rânduri și coloane corespund stărilor clasice ale sistemului de ieșire
și astfel are sens că expresia produce o matrice de densitate a sistemului de ieșire; acum nu este cazul
că pentru o alegere arbitrară a acestor matrice Krauss obținem un canal valid; există totuși o condiție destul de simplă
pe matrice care garantează că vom obține un canal valid și acea condiție este formula afișată chiar aici
în mod specific, dacă adunăm produsul AK dagger * AK peste toate valorile lui K
atunci trebuie să obținem matricea identitate și aceasta va fi matricea identitate ale cărei rânduri și coloane corespund
stărilor clasice ale sistemului de intrare; deci acea condiție trebuie să fie satisfăcută pentru ca maparea definită de
prima ecuație să fie un canal valid și se dovedește că fiecare canal are de fapt o reprezentare care ia
această formă atâta timp cât luăm n suficient de mare; iată câteva exemple de reprezentări Krauss
începând cu canalul qubit de resetare; putem obține o reprezentare Krauss pentru acest canal folosind
două matrice Krauss ket0 bra0 și ket0 bra1, deci n este egal cu doi în acest exemplu
putem introduce aceste alegeri în formula generală și avem doar doi termeni, deci este ușor de scris suma
și dacă simplificăm și recunoaștem că expresia din paranteză este urma lui rho, vedem că obținem
canalul qubit de resetare; putem verifica de asemenea că condiția necesară pe aceste matrice este îndeplinită și aceasta este o simplă chestiune de a introduce matricele Krauss
în ecuație și de a evalua și obținem matricea identitate după cum este necesar; pentru un alt exemplu să aruncăm din nou o privire la
canalul complet defazant; luarea matricelor ket0 bra0 și ket1 bra1 funcționează și aceasta poate fi verificată
extinzând suma și văzând destul de direct că obținem ce avem nevoie și din nou condiția necesară este îndeplinită; o
alternativă este să luăm A zero ca matricea identitate împărțit la rădăcina din 2 și A1 ca
Sigma Z împărțit la rădăcina din 2 și dacă evaluăm vedem că din nou obținem canalul complet defazant pe baza observației
WEBVTT
pe care am făcut-o despre acest canal puțin mai devreme în lecție și din nou condiția necesară este destul de simplă
de verificat ca exercițiu de parcurs dacă ai găsi asta util; consideră canalul complet depolarizant
care produce starea complet mixtă pentru fiecare intrare matrice de densitate; pentru acesta sunt necesare patru matrice Krauss
nu este posibil să vii cu o reprezentare Krauss unde n este trei sau mai puțin; iată o alegere care funcționează și
iată o alta; deci exercițiul este să verifici că aceste alegeri funcționează, precum și să verifici că condiția necesară
este satisfăcută; merită remarcat că a doua alternativă spune practic că este posibil să depolarizezi complet un qubit sau cu alte cuvinte să
îl randomizezi complet alegând aleatoriu una din cele patru matrice Pauli, inclusiv identitatea, și aplicând
operația unitară corespunzătoare qubit-ului; deci canalul complet depolarizant este un alt exemplu de canal
unitar mixt; ultima dintre cele trei reprezentări de canal pe care le vom acoperi este reprezentarea Choy; Manduin Choy
este un matematician care lucrează în teoria matricilor și alte subiecte, iar reprezentarea Choy este denumită în onoarea sa
bazată pe o lucrare cu adevărat elegantă pe care a publicat-o în 1975, care într-un anumit sens leagă toate lucrurile împreună; reprezentarea Choy
a unui canal fi este o singură matrice notată convențional jfi și în mod specific dacă
sistemul de intrare are n stări clasice și sistemul de ieșire are M stări clasice, atunci reprezentarea Choy a lui fi va fi
o matrice pătrată n * m pe n * m; înainte să îți spun exact cum este definită matricea, aș dori să menționez câteva
din proprietățile sale cheie care motivează reprezentarea într-un mod în care definiția actuală în sine poate că nu o face, cel puțin la
suprafață; mai întâi, spre deosebire atât de reprezentările Stinespring cât și de reprezentările Krauss, reprezentarea Choy
este o reprezentare așa-numită fidelă, ceea ce înseamnă că fiecare canal are doar una și aceasta este destul de importantă
deoarece spune că două canale sunt aceleași dacă și numai dacă reprezentările lor Choy sunt aceleași; deci dacă
ai două descrieri diferite ale canalelor, cum ar fi două reprezentări Stinespring diferite sau două reprezentări Krauss diferite, sau poate una
din fiecare, și vrei să știi dacă sunt de fapt același canal, poți calcula pur și simplu reprezentarea Choy și
verifica dacă sunt sau nu egale; a doua proprietate este că există condiții simple de verificat pe reprezentarea Choy care sunt adevărate dacă și numai
dacă avem un canal valid; acea proprietate nu este chiar atât de specială, putem spune același lucru despre celelalte două reprezentări, dar este o proprietate bună
de avut cu toate acestea și o vom discuta mai detaliat în scurt timp; mai este un lucru de notat despre reprezentarea Choy: deși reprezentăm
un canal prin o matrice, această matrice nu reprezintă direct canalul ca mapare liniară; de fapt este
mai natural să asociem reprezentarea Choy cu matricea de densitate care reprezintă o anumită stare
decât să ne gândim la reprezentarea Choy ca descriind o mapare liniară; este totuși posibil să recuperăm acțiunea canalului din
reprezentarea sa Choy folosind o formulă destul de simplă, dar nu atât de simplă ca înmulțirea
matriceală ordinară; este suficient ca preambul; să trecem la definiția actuală; să presupunem că avem un canal fi de la un sistem X la un sistem Y
și să presupunem că mulțimea stărilor clasice ale sistemului de intrare X este Sigma; nu va trebui să ne referim la mulțimea stărilor clasice a sistemului de ieșire, deci
pentru definiție nu este nevoie să o numim; reprezentarea Choy a lui fi este definită de expresia
arătată pe ecran; avem o sumă ce parcurge toate stările clasice A și B ale sistemului de intrare și
adunăm ket a bra B tensorizat cu canalul fi aplicat lui ket a bra B; deci această
reprezentare este definită de o formulă și există câteva moduri diferite prin care putem gândi la această formulă; înainte de a le discuta totuși, menționez
că uneori reprezentarea Choy este definită într-un mod ușor diferit unde ordinea celor doi factori tensoriali este inversată, adică
fi a lui ket a bra apare ca primul factor tensorial mai degrabă decât al doilea, dar cele două moduri diferite de a face asta sunt
echivalente până la această simetrie simplă; dar ceea ce înseamnă asta este că atunci când folosești această reprezentare este o idee bună
să clarifici ce ordine folosești; această ordine este modul în care se face în Qiskit și este de asemenea mai bun pentru
descrierea reprezentării vizual în termeni de matrice bloc; deci aceasta este cea cu care vom merge; pentru a fi mai precis despre descrierea matricei bloc
dacă presupunem că mulțimea stărilor clasice Sigma constă din numerele întregi de la zero la n minus unu
pentru un întreg pozitiv n, atunci putem scrie alternativ jfi ca matrice bloc după cum este arătat chiar aici pe
ecran; cu alte cuvinte, reprezentarea Choy a lui fi este matricea pe care o obținem evaluând fi pe fiecare dintre
matricele de intrare care au exact o intrare egală cu unu cu toate celelalte intrări zero și apoi aranjând
matrice în mod destul de natural; poate nu este clar a priori de ce am vrea să formăm o matrice ca aceasta, dar se
dovedește a fi foarte utilă; un lucru de remarcat este că mulțimea ce conține matricele ket a bra b
pe măsură ce a și b parcurg toți întregi de la 0 la n minus unu formează o bază pentru spațiul tuturor matricelor n pe n; deci dacă
ai această matrice, poți determina cu siguranță ce face fi pe o matrice arbitrară n pe n prin liniaritate
în mod specific prin luarea combinațiilor liniare adecvate ale blocurilor; deci matricea jfi determină de fapt în mod unic
fi ca mapare liniară; un alt mod de a gândi la reprezentarea Choy a unui canal este că
reprezintă o stare ca matrice de densitate când este normalizată, în mod specific prin împărțirea la numărul de
stări clasice ale sistemului de intrare, pe care voi continua să îl notez cu n în literă mică; aceasta ne va da întotdeauna o
matrice de densitate care este adesea denumită starea Choy a canalului; iată cum funcționează asta în mai multe detalii
imaginează-ți mai întâi că avem două copii identice ale sistemului de intrare și considerăm vectorul de stare cuantic s
afișat pe ecran, care reprezintă o stare maximally entangled a acestei perechi de sisteme identice; de
exemplu, dacă Sigma este alfabetul binar, atunci aceasta este o stare fi+, dar putem gândi la o stare definită analog pentru
orice alegere de Sigma și ceea ce obținem este o stare foarte puternic entangled și de fapt este atât de entangled pe cât poate fi
dată această alegere de sisteme; pentru a obține reprezentarea ca matrice de densitate a stării, înmulțim vectorul de stare cu transpusa sa conjugată ca de obicei și
acesta este aspectul ei; și în final dacă ne gândim la reprezentarea Choy a canalului împărțită la n, vedem că este starea
pe care am obține-o dacă am aplica canalul fi celui de-al doilea sistem; sub forma unei figuri, iată
cum arată asta: avem două copii ale sistemului X în această stare maximally entangled s; canalul fi este
aplicat celui de-al doilea sistem, care este cel de sus din diagramă, iar starea rezultată este starea Choy a lui fi; desigur, nu am numi în mod normal
două sisteme diferite la fel; în general nu este util să dai același nume la două lucruri diferite, dar are sens
WEBVTT
în acest caz doar pentru a face această conexiune cu reprezentările Choy; există câteva implicații pe care le putem trage imediat din acest mod de
a privi reprezentările Choy; una este că, deoarece starea Choy este o matrice de densitate, presupunând că fi este un
canal valid, concluzionăm că reprezentarea Choy a lui fi trebuie să fie pozitiv semi-definită; amintește-ți că este o
cerință pe care o impunem canalelor că transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate și aceasta
este doar un caz special al acesteia; a doua implicație este că dacă luăm starea Choy pentru orice canal fi și
then aruncăm sistemul de ieșire Y, trebuie să rămânem cu starea complet mixtă pe sistemul de intrare X; asta
deoarece aplicarea unui canal unui sistem și apoi aruncarea sistemului rezultant la gunoi este echivalent cu aruncarea pur și simplu a sistemului original la
gunoi și dacă am face asta cu starea noastră maximally entangled, matricea de densitate cu care am rămâne ar fi
matricea identitate împărțită la n sau cu alte cuvinte starea complet mixtă pentru sistemul X; ideea în termeni mai
matematici este că compunerea oricărui canal cu urma pe sistemul de ieșire trebuie să fie egală cu urma pe
sistemul de intrare și asta deoarece canalele trebuie să păstreze urma în virtutea faptului că sunt mapări liniare care
transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate; odată ce avem această ecuație, putem elimina numitorul n
din ambele părți pentru a obține o condiție ușor mai curată; în cuvinte, efectuând urma parțială pe sistemul de ieșire
al reprezentării Choy a unui canal trebuie să ne dea matricea identitate pe sistemul de intrare; deci în rezumat, reprezentările Choy
ale canalelor sunt întotdeauna pozitiv semi-definite și dacă urmărim sistemul de ieșire, rămânem în mod necesar
cu matricea identitate pe sistemul de intrare; se dovedește că acestea nu sunt doar condiții necesare, ci
sunt și suficiente, ceea ce înseamnă că dacă fi este o mapare liniară arbitrară și aceste două condiții sunt ambele adevărate
atunci trebuie în realitate să fie că fi este un canal valid și vom vedea de ce acesta este cazul la sfârșitul lecției
să aruncăm o privire la câteva exemple începând cu canalul complet defazant; pentru a calcula reprezentarea Choy, este doar o chestiune de
a evalua formula; canalul complet defazant lasă ket a bra B neschimbat când a egal B și altfel ieșirea
este zero; deci termenii din sumă care supraviețuiesc sunt cei unde a egal B și rezultatul este exprimat pe
ecran folosind notația Dirac; putem vedea asta de asemenea ca o matrice bloc; Delta lasă intrările diagonale intacte și anulează
intrările din afara diagonalei și astfel rămânem cu o matrice cu unu în colțurile din stânga sus și din dreapta jos cu toate
intrările lor zero și aceasta este consistentă cu prima expresie; pentru un alt exemplu, să considerăm din nou canalul complet depolarizant;
putem începe prin a scrie formula și la fel ca în exemplul anterior nu obținem nicio contribuție la sumă
când a nu este egal cu B și de această dată când a egal B obținem starea complet mixtă și putem simplifica asta
pentru a obține 1/2 * matricea identitate 2x2 tensorizată cu ea însăși, care este 1/2 * matricea identitate 4x4
putem gândi asta de asemenea în termeni de matrice bloc și în mod natural obținem același rezultat; și ca
ultim exemplu să considerăm canalul identitate pentru un singur qubit; este un exemplu ușor; iată formula și
desigur canalul identitate nu face nimic și putem gândi rezultatul ca fiind de două ori matricea de densitate asociată cu o stare fi+, ceea ce este
consistent cu ce ne așteptăm gândindu-ne la starea Choy a acestui canal; și iată sub forma unei matrice bloc; remarcă în particular că reprezentarea Choy
a canalului identitate nu este matricea identitate; este această matrice; am văzut acum trei moduri diferite
de a reprezenta canalele în termeni matematici, și anume reprezentările Stinespring, reprezentările Krauss și reprezentările Choy
și avem de asemenea definiția unui canal, care este că un canal este o mapare liniară care transformă întotdeauna
matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate chiar și când canalul este aplicat doar la o parte dintr-un sistem compus; o întrebare foarte naturală și foarte importantă
de adresat în acest moment este: cum știm că acestea sunt toate echivalente? de exemplu, cum știm că fiecare
mapare descrisă de oricare dintre aceste reprezentări este de fapt un canal valid și cum știm că nu lăsăm afară niciun canal?
restul lecției descrie cum poate fi raționat toate acestea matematic; dacă ești dispus să accepți echivalența acestor lucruri și nu ești interesat de cum poate
fi raționat, atunci te simți liber să sari peste restul videoclipului; dar eu personal cred că argumentul este destul de
elegant și este un exemplu bun al unui stil particular de demonstrație matematică ce apare din când în când în teoria informației cuantice; nu voi trece
prin toate detaliile; unele dintre ele le voi lăsa ție sau le poți găsi în conținutul scris pentru această lecție, unde totul este scris în
detaliu; dar sper să prezint o imagine destul de clară a modului în care funcționează totul; ceea ce vrem să facem este să demonstrăm
echivalența unei colecții de afirmații și modul în care putem face asta este să stabilim un ciclu de implicații; în particular, vom porni
cu definiția unui canal, adică o mapare liniară care transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate
din această definiție putem raționa că reprezentarea Choy a acestui canal trebuie să satisfacă cele două condiții pe care le-am
identificat deja și de fapt am făcut deja asta; aceasta a fost discutată în contextul stării Choy a unui canal; apoi uităm
de definiție și lucrăm din reprezentarea Choy și dat cu cele două condiții ale noastre pe reprezentările Choy, concluzionăm că trebuie să existe o
reprezentare Krauss a mapării fi; facem apoi un lucru analog, uităm de reprezentările Choy și lucrăm
dintr-o reprezentare Krauss arbitrară și din aceasta putem raționa că trebuie să existe o reprezentare Stinespring pentru maparea fi; și apropo, aceste
argumente vor fi mecanice într-un anumit sens, ceea ce ne permite să efectuăm efectiv conversiile conform săgeților pentru canale specifice dacă vrem
să facem asta; ultima implicație este să rațonăm că dacă avem o reprezentare Stinespring pentru o mapare fi atunci
acea mapare trebuie de fapt să fie un canal valid și din nou am făcut deja asta; de această dată în contextul reprezentărilor Stinespring
în total, aceste patru implicații relevă că aceste patru lucruri sunt toate echivalente deoarece poți porni de la oricare dintre ele și
urma implicațiile tranzitiv pentru a ajunge la oricare dintre celelalte; vom porni cu prima implicație
care este că dacă avem un canal fi adică o mapare liniară ce transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate, atunci are o reprezentare Choy
care satisface cele două condiții pe care le-am identificat mai devreme, și anume că este pozitiv semi-definită
și dacă urmărim sistemul de ieșire obținem identitatea pe sistemul de intrare; și după cum am menționat adineauri, am
acoperit deja această implicație în contextul stărilor Choy; în particular, când împărțim reprezentarea Choy a unui canal la n, numărul de
stări clasice ale sistemului de intrare, obținem o matrice de densitate și mai mult, starea redusă a
sistemului de intrare X pentru acea stare este starea complet mixtă sau cu alte cuvinte matricea identitate împărțită la n; eliminarea numitorului ne dă cele
două condiții ale noastre; deci această implicație este destul de rapidă și ușoară deoarece am acoperit-o deja
WEBVTT
acum să aruncăm o privire la a doua implicație; de această dată pornim cu reprezentarea Choy a unei mapări pe care
o presupunem că satisface cele două cerințe și scopul nostru este să găsim o reprezentare Krauss pentru această mapare care
satisface cerința despre care am vorbit mai devreme; această implicație este destul de mecanică în un sens, vom avea nevoie de
puțin de algebră liniară și va fi în principal o chestiune de manipulare a matricilor și vectorilor într-un mod destul de ingenios
pornind cu presupunerea că reprezentarea Choy este pozitiv semi-definită, ceea ce este prima din cele două cerințe pe care le presupunem că sunt
în vigoare; noțiunea de matrice pozitiv semi-definită este fundamental importantă în informația cuantică și nu doar în contextul matricelor de densitate
este absolut critică aici; nu am putea face asta să funcționeze fără ea; în particular, presupunerea
că jfi este pozitiv semi-definită ne permite să o exprimăm în forma arătată pe ecran pentru o anumită alegere de
vectori s0 până la S N minus unu și o anumită alegere a unui întreg pozitiv n; menționez explicit că aceștia nu sunt
neapărat vectori unitari; un mod de a obține o expresie ca aceasta este din teorema spectrală pentru matrice
pozitiv semi-definite, care a fost discutată în lecția anterioară; aici nu vedem nicio valoare proprie apărând explicit ca în
o descompunere spectrală, dar amintește-ți că valorile proprii ale matricelor pozitiv semi-definite sunt întotdeauna numere reale non-negative și de asemenea ține minte că
nu cerem ca acești vectori S 0 până la S N minus unu să fie vectori unitari; deci ce putem face este să luăm rădăcinile pătrate ale
valorilor proprii și să le înmulțim în vectorii proprii unitari pe care îi obținem dintr-o descompunere spectrală pentru a obține acești
vectori s0 până la S N minus 1; de fapt nu este important pentru această demonstrație ca acești vectori să fie ortogonali; îi
obținem dintr-o descompunere spectrală, dar nu vom folosi asta aici și dacă am fi avut o expresie diferită a lui jfi ca aceasta care nu provine din teorema spectrală
atunci aceea ar fi la fel de bine; acum descompunem fiecare dintre acești vectori după cum este arătat pe ecran și
aceasta este la fel cum am face dacă acești vectori ar fi vectori de stare cuantici ai unei perechi de sisteme XY și am efectua
o măsurătoare în baza standard pe sistemul X; ca să fie clar, nu măsurăm nimic aici; pur și simplu scriem acești vectori în această formă, ceea ce
este întotdeauna posibil; și acum iată trucul: definim matricele Krauss a0 până la a n minus unu luând K
A-urile de la capătul din față a acestor vectori s0 până la S N minus unu, răsturnându-le astfel încât devin bra A-uri mai degrabă
decât ket A-uri, și punându-le în dreapta după cum este arătat în ecuația de pe ecran; un mod de a gândi
la asta este că în esență împaturim acești vectori pentru a forma matrice, astfel încât dacă am stivui coloanele lui AK una deasupra celeilalte am
obține înapoi s; deci aceste matrice au exact aceleași intrări ca și vectorii corespunzători, dar pur și simplu
am rearanjat intrările diferit pentru a obține matrice; dar putem gândi la aceste matrice și pur și simplu simbolic în termeni de notație Dirac
după cum este scris aici; și acum la acest punct există o întrebare evidentă: de ce ar trebui asta să funcționeze? ei bine, să nu insistăm prea mult
pe de ce funcționează; să verificăm pur și simplu că funcționează; pentru a face asta, să definim o nouă mapare care este maparea definită de
aceste matrice unde le tratăm ca matrice Krauss; ce putem face acum este să calculăm reprezentarea Choy a
acestei noi mapări și vom vedea că este egală cu reprezentarea Choy a mapării fi cu care am pornit și
deoarece reprezentările Choy sunt fidele, asta înseamnă că cele două mapări sunt de fapt egale; nu voi trece prin algebră în acest videoclip;
poți verifica asta singur; este destul de mecanic și este o bună practică și tot ce ai nevoie pentru asta este chiar
pe ecran; nu am spus încă nimic despre cele două condiții din cele două casete, dar se
dovedesc a fi echivalente și un mod de a stabili asta este să verifici ecuația afișată în josul ecranului
litera T aici de altfel se referă la transpunerea matriceală, la care te poți gândi alternativ ca la
maparea liniară care transformă ket a bra B în ket b bra a și este pur și simplu ceva ce este necesar pentru a face formula să funcționeze; deci în
rezumat, cu siguranță este nevoie de algebră pentru această implicație, dar după cum am spus, este totul destul de mecanic
practic gimnastică cu indici cum le numesc unii oameni, dar dacă parcurgi asta și îți dai creierului o șansă să digere, este posibil să
pleci cu o înțelegere mai bună a modului în care se relaționează reprezentările Choy și reprezentările Krauss; a treia implicație ne permite
să mergem de la o reprezentare Krauss a unei mapări fi unde condiția obișnuită este în vigoare la o reprezentare Stinespring; aceasta este destul de
similară în spirit cu implicația anterioară în sensul că este mecanică și poate fi privită și verificată în termeni pur algebrici; ideea
este de fapt destul de simplă: ce putem face este să luăm matricele noastre Krauss și să formăm parte dintr-o matrice mai mare stivuindu-le
una deasupra celeilalte după cum este arătat pe ecran; odată completată, aceasta ne va da matricea unitară U pentru o
reprezentare Stinespring; matricele unitare trebuie să fie matrice pătrate, deci va trebui să completăm cu atâtea
coloane câte mai avem nevoie, dar nu va face nicio diferență ce sunt, atâta timp cât obținem o matrice
unitară; dacă lăsăm momentan deoparte preocuparea că U este unitar și ne concentrăm doar pe maparea liniară definită de
reprezentarea Stinespring pe care o obținem din această matrice U, atunci ceea ce găsim este că maparea este egală cu
maparea originală fi definită de reprezentarea Krauss cu care am pornit; aceasta este o altă parte a demonstrației pe care nu o voi parcurge în acest videoclip; poți
găsi detaliile în conținutul scris pentru această lecție, dar poți dori alternativ să îți iei ceva timp și să lucrezi prin asta singur; ține
minte ca de obicei pentru serie că folosim convenția de ordonare ket pentru a interpreta diagrama, deci W și G vor
corespunde factorilor tensoriali din partea stângă în ecuații; și apropo, dacă
parcurgi asta vei găsi că deoarece avem ket0 bra zero ca factor tensorial din stânga în ecuația
pe care trebuie să o verificăm, singura parte din U care are vreo relevanță este cea dată de matricele Krauss; deci atâta timp cât completăm
coloanele lui U într-un mod care îl face unitar, suntem bine; dar desigur asta necesită că coloanele formate de a0 până la a n minus
unu când le stivuim una deasupra celeilalte sunt ortonormale și acesta este locul unde condiția pe care o impunem reprezentărilor Krauss intră în joc
și este de fapt precis echivalentă cu faptul că coloanele sunt ortonormale; relațiile matematice relevante necesare pentru a trage
această concluzie sunt arătate în josul ecranului; deci fă o pauză și verifică dacă alegi, sau din nou
consultă conținutul scris pentru mai multe detalii; pe scurt, ceea ce se întâmplă în ambele această implicație și în
precedenta este că descriem aceleași operații matematice în moduri diferite dar echivalente; inima
bătătoare a tuturor acestora este în esență înmulțirea matriceală; a patra și ultima implicație stabilește că dacă avem
o reprezentare Stinespring pentru o anumită mapare, atunci acea mapare trebuie de fapt să fie un canal valid și după cum am indicat
mai devreme, am acoperit deja această implicație când am discutat reprezentările Stinespring; în rezumat și în
WEBVTT
termeni ușor diferiți: introducerea unui sistem workspace inițializat este un canal valid; asta deoarece tensorizarea unei matrice de densitate fixe
cu o matrice de densitate dată ne dă întotdeauna o matrice de densitate și este o mapare liniară prin biliniaritatea
produselor tensoriale; operațiile unitare sunt întotdeauna canale valide după cum am discutat mai devreme în lecție; urmărirea unui sistem este un canal valid deoarece
urma parțială este o mapare liniară care transformă întotdeauna matricele de densitate în matrice de densitate; și în final, compunerile de
canale sunt întotdeauna canale, ceea ce este destul de simplu, dar merită cu siguranță observat în sine; și cu cele
patru implicații pe care tocmai le-am acoperit, am stabilit echivalența celor trei reprezentări de canal ale noastre împreună cu
definiția originală a unui canal; în particular, am pornit cu definiția unui canal, am văzut cum acea definiție implică că reprezentarea sa Choy
satisface în mod necesar două condiții de bază, apoi am văzut cum acele condiții ne permit să găsim o reprezentare Krauss care la rândul său
ne permite să găsim o reprezentare Stinespring și în final am văzut că existența unei reprezentări Stinespring revelă că avem de fapt
un canal valid; desigur există detalii tehnice și nu este neapărat simplu, mai ales
când îl vezi pentru prima dată, dar ceea ce este interesant și demn de remarcat este că aceste implicații sunt stabilite într-un mod care într-adevăr face
lucrurile cât mai ușoare posibil și în matematică nu ar trebui să simți niciodată rușine că mergi pe calea cea mai ușoară; de
exemplu, nu este deloc evident că fiecare canal are o reprezentare Stinespring sau o reprezentare Krauss
dar este relativ ușor să concluzionăm că reprezentarea Choy a fiecărui canal satisface cele două condiții pe care le-am asociat cu ea și asta
ne permite să urmăm un drum mai mult sau mai puțin algebric spre celelalte două reprezentări; într-un mod similar, ultima
implicație de la o reprezentare Stinespring înapoi la definiție este de asemenea relativ directă și
ne permite să concluzionăm că obținem doar canale și nicio altă mapare din reprezentările Choy, presupunând că
condițiile necesare sunt îndeplinite; și după cum am sugerat înainte, modul în care argumentăm aceste implicații este suficient de mecanic pentru a ne permite să convertim ușor
între reprezentări și dacă te întorci la câteva dintre exemplele pe care le-am acoperit mai devreme în lecție vei descoperi că este de fapt posibil să
convertești între reprezentări uneori destul de ușor și direct; și acesta este sfârșitul
lecției, care a fost în întregime despre canale; am vorbit despre ce sunt și am privit câteva exemple de bază; am discutat trei moduri în care canalele pot
fi reprezentate și am aprofundat câteva detalii tehnice care stabilesc echivalența acestor reprezentări; eu
sper că te vei alătura mie pentru lecția următoare, care este în întregime despre măsurători în formularea generală a informației cuantice; la revedere până atunci